you're scared that you're going to lose
friends you're scared that you're going
to be alone as you start to go out on a
journey of self-improvement how can
people find the courage to do that one
thing they can do is contemplate the
consequences of not doing it you lose
friends well you're going to lose the
friends who don't want the best for you
those are the friends you want in 10
years and you lose friends well maybe
gain better friends but you have to
contemplate the price you pay for in
action and this is something I did with
my clients all the time it's like I
don't want to change jobs well no wonder
you're in this job you hate and it's 10
years from now how does that look think
about that you know perfectly well it's
going to get worse which is more
frightening action or inaction well the
thing about inaction is you're blind to
it do not make the assumption that
inaction has no price